Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buon pomeriggio e grazie dell'invito.
Mi chiamo Anna Spertini,
sono un'insegnante,
insegno ai bambini e agli adolescenti.
E ho trascorso gli ultimi
cinque mesi della mia vita
a studiare le microespressioni facciali,
e le emozioni ad esse correlate.
Ecco: questa, per esempio,
è un'espressione di gioia sincera.
Questa, invece, è l'espressione
che fanno i miei conoscenti
quando dico loro
come ho trascorso l'estate.
C'è un certo disagio,
fa una certa impressione
perché effettivamente
le microespressioni facciali
sono spesso correlate e associate
allo smascheramento delle menzogne.
Questo anche grazie
a un telefilm di qualche anno fa.
Ma non sanno, le persone,
che applicando queste tecniche
a un altro settore, come quello didattico,
siamo in grado di ottenere una
comunicazione maggiore con gli studenti
e anche una maggiore
consapevolezza di se stessi.
Sono anche una mamma.
Mio figlio si chiama
Alessandro, ha 9 anni,
e studia il violino con il metodo Suzuki.
Il metodo Suzuki è un metodo innovativo
nell'insegnamento della musica,
universalmente riconosciuto
e chiamato anche
"metodo della lingua madre".
Fu creato nel secolo scorso
da Shinichi Suzuki
che è un violinista
e insegnante giapponese
e il fondamento principale
di questo metodo
è che tutti possono apprendere
dal loro ambiente.
Quindi quando crei
l'ambiente giusto e stimolante,
stimoli anche le stesse
situazioni nello studente,
e così favorisci l'apprendimento.
Condizione essenziale del metodo Suzuki
è la partecipazione
di almeno un genitore
nel percorso di studio.
E infatti il successo
di ogni programma Suzuki
sta proprio nella buona qualità
di questo cosiddetto "triangolo Suzuki"
che è formato dalla relazione
di collaborazione
tra insegnante, genitore e bambino.
Ecco, questa è una classe di violino
della Scuola Suzuki di Siena.
Il maestro di violino di mio figlio
si chiama Alessio Nacuzi
e invia solitamente
diverse e-mail ai genitori
per supportarli nel loro ruolo
di genitori Suzuki
e per aiutare i loro figli, appunto,
nell'apprendimento del violino a casa.
La primavera scorsa,
Alessio invia una mail a tutti i genitori
che, tra le altre cose,
contiene un link
al sito Web di Paul Ekman.
Paul Ekman è un ricercatore
che ha dedicato
tutta la sua vita alla ricerca
delle microespressioni facciali
e delle emozioni ad esse correlate.
Vado a visitare il sito Web,
e vedo subito che all'interno
c'è una grandissima quantità
di informazioni interessanti
non solo per il lavoro che svolgo,
ma anche come mamma,
per aiutare mio figlio
con lo studio del violino.
Il materiale è tantissimo
ed è anche abbastanza costoso,
quindi chiedo ad Alessio
se è possibile condividerne la spesa.
Alessio accetta, e così condividiamo
anche i momenti di studio.
Trascorriamo l'intera estate a studiare
e arriviamo a fine estate
che riusciamo a conseguire
il FACS Coders Certificate.
Questo è un certificato
che viene solitamente conseguito
da persone che poi vanno
a collaborare come esperti
con la Polizia o con il Tribunale.
Ma noi vogliamo applicarlo alla didattica,
perché siamo convinti
che potrà darci risultati soprendenti.
E, in questo frangente,
conosco anche meglio Alessio.
Conosco alcuni dettagli della sua vita,
e come è arrivato a Siena,
e scopro così che,
come Paul Ekman
ha dedicato tutta la sua vita
allo studio delle
microespressioni facciali,
Alessio ha dedicato tutta la sua vita
non soltanto alla musica e al violino,
ma anche alla ricerca di un metodo
didattico unico nel suo genere.
Immaginatevi, infatti,
di prendere diversi strumenti
e tecniche di comunicazione,
usate solitamente in settori di nicchia,
e di applicarli alla didattica.
L'effetto è immediato:
tra insegnante e studenti
si crea una comunicazione
e un'empatia profonda;
i risultati vengono raggiunti
in tempi molto più rapidi,
e con un benessere di fondo stabile.
Il maestro Alessio Nacuzi
è convinto che sia possibile,
tramite l'utilizzo di diversi metodi,
come il metodo Suzuki,
il Mental Training, l'NLP Coaching,
il metodo Feldenkrais, il LAB Profile,
riuscire a ottenere
una situazione per la quale
nel momento della performance,
e quindi del concerto, dell'esecuzione,
il bambino sia in una
situazione di zero stress
e quindi benessere di fondo stabile.
Molte università straniere e italiane
si sono rivelate interessate
alla ricerca di Alessio.
Tra queste anche
il Royal College di Londra,
e ovviamente anche
il Paul Ekman Group
che ci ha donato
parte del materiale di studio.
E allora il passaggio è:
come facciamo per definire
il livello di stress nei bambini?
Esiste un test semplice e affidabile
che si chiama test del cortisolo salivare.
Consiste nel prelevare
un piccolo campione di saliva
dal soggetto, nel momento
della performance,
e quindi in questo caso del concerto,
per misurare appunto
la quantità di cortisolo.
Quando questo ormone,
che viene prodotto
dalle ghiandole surrenali,
è presente in quantità elevata,
indica una condizione di stress.
Alessio Nacuzi nei suoi anni di esperienza
ha applicato proprio questo metodo
su tanti bambini, i suoi studenti.
E ha visto che, effettivamente,
si può applicare, si può fare,
e i risultati ci sono.
Io sono una testimonianza
entusiasta di questo
perché ho visto che mio figlio,
soltanto dopo due anni
di studio del violino,
è ora in grado di suonare,
a memoria, più di 50 pezzi,
tra cui anche pezzi molto complessi.
E quindi pensate un po'
a come potrebbe essere
applicare un metodo di questo genere
anche ad altre materie,
tipo la matematica,
la storia, le lingue straniere.
Avremmo modo, finalmente,
di dare la possibilità ai nostri figli
di trarre il massimo vantaggio
da questo aspetto dell'apprendimento
che li accompagnerà
per tutta la loro vita.
E arriviamo, così,
all'espressione di gioia sincera
che vi ho mostrato all'inizio.
Immaginatevi i vostri figli
felici di imparare,
e fortemente motivati a farlo.
E immaginatevi anche
la vostra, di felicità,
quando realizzerete
ciò che avete fatto per loro.
Grazie.
(Applausi)